um
okay so today i'm going to talk mainly
about um
about how you get
circuit lower bounds
if you
that basically any way of de-randomizing
a generic way of the randomizing
algorithm is going to give you some kind
of circuit lower bound so last class we
last lecture we saw that any way
or if you've got a circuit lower bound
you can use that to give this universal
de-randomization of algorithms by
constructing pseudo-random generators
and here we're going to say that that in
some sense this
the
this is necessary
um
okay
so um
and uh so but before i before i talk
about that uh
valentin and antonina on the way to to
here today pointed out that
i sort of was giving a historical talk
without really making it relevant to
some of the other things
the
the um
you know giving any kind of directions
where we could connect it to the other
lines of research
what we'd want to do to update it to to
connect to other lines of research
being discussed so i thought about two
possible problems
specific problems that we could think
about
that would connect this general question
of when can you de-randomize algorithms
to
some of the other more general
issues that have been that have arisen
in some of the other talks
so one of the thing questions that was
asked i believe yesterday
after seeing some of the randomized
algorithms
that solved np complete problems exactly
were is there a general method for
derandomizing
such algorithms
okay
so
one way of formalizing what such
algorithms is uh is due to um
to
pavel pudlock and mohan patturi um
they observe that many of the exact
algorithms for the hard problems have
the following form they're actually a
polynomial time algorithm
even though we're we're
interested in the exponential the exact
exponential time but this polynomial
time algorithm the pavel heard his name
has only an exponentially small success
probability so we have to repeat it many
times about one in the success
probability times
before where we're very likely to see
one that have one of these runs
succeed and since we actually care about
the exact
exponential complexity
running the algorithm one over epsilon
times is very different from running the
algorithm one over epsilon squared times
and for many of
many of the algorithms that we've seen
one over epsilon times is good because
it's much less than exponent than
exhaustive search whereas one over
epsilon squared times would be horrible
much worse than naive algorithms
so when we
the challenge in derandomizing such an
algorithm
is um
is to try to preserve exactly
this this number number of um
uh
the number of repetitions
implicit in in the randomization
so um
so we saw that um
so that
you know for general deranization where
you don't have this asymmetry between
the
the success probability and the time
when they're about the same
we could de-randomize by constructing a
pseudo-random generator that took some
number of n-bits to some number t bits
so that
the problem of
a half plus epsilon solving the
randomness distinguishing
problem for g
was t hard
okay
so um in this kind of algorithm you
would get the same thing so in the
general setting there's symmetry between
t and epsilon and we want to get the
number of random bits you know the ideal
thing would be to get it about log t and
log one over epsilon logarithmic and one
another epsilon so that when you do
exhaustive search through all two to the
n
strings pseudorandom strings you have
overhead that's polynomial in t and
polynomial and one over epsilon
but in our setting
t is much smaller than epsilon
or one over epsilon
so
the question is can we have a
pseudo-random generator or under what
assumptions can we have a pseudo-random
generator where the seed length could be
even close to t just a little bit less
than t because we're willing to have
mildly or sub exponential overhead
in
in t
but we want it to be very tight
in terms of this epsilon
okay so the we could only afford
about one times log one over epsilon
uh
you know the dependence on on epsilon
would have to be exactly log one over
epsilon or maybe like one plus little o
of one times log one over epsilon uh
that would that would raise
epsilon to some power but something that
would be even small
you know wouldn't diminish the savings
by by
even a constant factor
so if we had such a construction i think
that would successfully answer the
question of um
you know of can we de-randomize this
broad class of algorithms
um
and of course we'll probably have to
make because we're
we show that some you know that
de-randomization
in general
implies circuit lower bounds you're
going to probably have to make some
assumption about some
some hardness assumption for some
function somewhere to get started on
this so i'm saying can we do this under
any reasonable
circuit complexity assumption
so i'm putting a dollar amount of 200 on
this problem
um
so
uh so another problem that we talked
about on the way here
i think
is um it's a little bit even more
general okay
so we
ryan talked about
circuit
circuit
analysis
problems and
so
and how some concrete circuit analysis
problems are sort of linked together and
linked to lower bounds
so um in this paper with
barack at all well many authors
that introduced some notions of
obfuscator before destroying them
but has come back because one our
weakest definition is that we proved
that these notions of obfuscator were
actually impossible except for one well
it was too weak to do anything that one
has come back and it's proved to be very
surprisingly useful
okay
so anyway
so um
one consequence of the strong
obfuscators that don't exist would have
been this kind of general rice's theorem
for polynomial time computable functions
let's say
so the the the sort of conjecture
is that
that the circuit analysis problems are
hard
you know in a formal sense
so what i mean so say that we have any
property of a function
call it p and this is probably bad
because p stands for polynomial time but
not here just property
the f the property is white box solvable
if given a circuit c
you can tell whether the function
computed by that circuit has property p
and it's black box solvable if
using just an oracle for f the function
f
and an upper bound on the size bound so
being like given a circuit given any
circuit what what can you do without
even understanding the circuit
you can know that the the circuit
computes a function of at most its own
size circuit complexity
okay so we're also going to give an
upper bound on the circuit complexity of
this function
to the black box algorithm and say
decide and ask it to decide whether the
function has property b
and the conjecture is that any property
that's solvable in the white box setting
in polynomial time so this is kind of a
generic circuit analysis problem this
property p
and we're saying that any
non-trivial circuit you know anything
that can be solved black box doesn't
really involve in analyzing the circuit
just says i'm just going to use the
circuit
without thinking about it
something in the white box solvable
setting
involves looking at the circuit and so
the conjecture is that circuit analysis
problems are generally hard so the only
things that are solvable in the white
box setting are those that are solvable
in the black box setting
okay so what i'm asking
okay so one thing you could do is try to
prove this conjecture if it seems very
difficult involves as a first step
proving p not equal np
and so on
because that's a circuit analysis
problem
but
what i'd like to say is
we're saying
a generic way of saying circuit analysis
is connected to lower balance is to say
if this conjecture is false if some
property is solvable in the black box
setting it's a white box heading that's
not solvable in the box box setting
then
some kind of circuit lower bound follows
yes
i'm wondering
if it's if it was black box oracle
access because what's to stop some
nonsense where the circuit behaves
almost according to the property but has
like is off by one bit at a particular
location
um
that would not be black box solvable
either
sorry so that wouldn't be
how do you test whether
okay so let's take sad algorithms right
they have exactly that property
so sat
is um
saying is the function identically zero
or is it different from zero at one one
could be random input
and so
you know it's not clear that that that's
ever white box solvable
okay
thanks
it's clear it's not black box solvable
if it could be a random place
yes it seems like a win-win situation
and if the conjecture is true then you
get a lower point the conjecture is
false then you are asking for a lower
bond
sure i like to win
there has to be a quantitative loss you
expect or like
yeah well well so also um
that we have a lot of other win-win
you know well when or or if you're
you're you're not rooting for lower
bounds lose lose
you're right because we're saying say
like take de-randomization either
de-randomization is hard or i'm going to
show you
you get a circuit lower bound
unfortunately
the hardness is for a uniform model
in the lower bound is for a non-uniform
model
and so
you can't just say you get a lower bound
um and again here i'd be like talking
about uniform
white box versus
um
but you know
if some version gives you a win-win
argument that gives you a lower bound
then i will up the up the prize for the
the award
okay
so um
so this i'll also give um
like offer 200 for it but um
so up to 200
because it's kind of vague
and it's going to be judged whether it's
worth the full two hundred dollars
because be judged by a committee
or the commit the the membership of the
committee is valentine
or the valentin himself
then i think he'll give himself the full
prize
that would be my conjecture
okay
so um this is like the general statement
and it's a little bit vague because
saying like some kind of circuit lower
bound follows some kind of lower bound
follows um but it is the statement of
the problems clear
yeah
are we going to explain how the lower
bounds follow
these are problems that i'm offering
money for
not things i know how to do the blue
statement is the question yes okay
it's done yeah so
okay so if you
for the right statement you don't need
the dollar incentive i guess right
so
um
yeah
of course if you could somehow prove the
negation of this
as well but the
i'm not quite sure how you would do that
without proving upper bounds
you know for everything that we could
imagine
since this is very vague
yes
the red conjecture is in the is
described in the rock at all paper
yeah
oh it's worth a million dollar well if
you prove the conjecture if you disprove
the conjecture it's worth it
right so
oh i mean yeah so the blue part is worth
up to two hundred dollars that's why
it's in blue
yeah
and this whole thing is in blue
so white box solvable
is this for any representation of the
circuit because there's like some that
are more
so so here i'm asking for
general representations of a circuit but
um say antonina is working on like
subclasses of circuits so the general
question is interesting for subclasses
of circuits as well
special forms of circuit
and if you prove it if you prove it for
some subclass of circuits rather than
for general circuits
it'll be up to the committee to decide
your reward
um so any questions about about these
and i'll go on to something fairly
different just to make sure so in the
black blocks
you said that it's been time if it's big
time in s
yes
is given in unary yeah
so p time in n the number of inputs to
the function ns
decide whether it has that property is
that saying given any c that computes
that's right
yeah so you have to be able to decide it
for an arbitrary c
not
the best kc
there are ways to there are ways to make
you know the function that just says
the all zero function easy to see that
it's all zero and ways to make it hard
to see that it's all zero
so um
so last time we saw
a couple of results like um
one from
from bfnw
says if
say x is not
in p slash poly
then
then
the circuit
approximation value approximation
problem
is in time
infinitely often
to the end to the epsilon for every
epsilon
okay so you get a sub exponential d
randomization of this problem that can
actually code every every kind of
probabilistic decision
uh problem
pro decision problem for probabilistic
algorithms
okay so um
so what i want to show you today so that
says if we've got a strong enough
non-uniform lower bound then we get a
deranimization
okay and we said that's kind of this
kind of intuitive connection because
this the randomization problem is a kind
of meta problem and so trying you know
the intuition is that
it's input is a circuit and
that circuit is trying to distinguish
its random tape from pseudorandom
from pseudorandomness
so
today i want to i want to
show a version of a result from ikw igw
gives quantitatively stronger results
i'm going to show like the easy version
and uh saying something like we get an
implication in the other direction so
let's say that cap
now i'm just going to say if cap is in
polynomial time
then
we'll get a lower bound
not quite for x
but for one class above
x
so it doesn't have polynomial size
circuits
um
so
i guess when i was again like on the way
to to breakfast i would explain what's
going on in this kind of result because
um
so valentin was saying well what if
people
you know
don't care about non-uniform complexity
they just care about uniform complexity
and what this result was saying so even
if all you care about is if all you
think you care about is is uniform kinds
of complexity like probabilistic
algorithms and deterministic algorithms
you actually have to think about
non-uniform complexity so you can't pick
that apart so saying like it's really
good it's a special case of a general my
my general philosophy of mathematics is
that mathematics is like a bowl of
spaghetti
okay
so
you know you're interested in one noodle
but before you know if you start like
slurping that one noodle
you're gonna be having a tour of the
whole bowl
and everything else you know someone
else is trying to understand another
noodle
they're going to intersect at some point
and maybe be stuck together
okay so this is saying like
at least for complexity the uniform
classes and the non-uniform classes are
strands of noodle that at least at some
point are stuck together
and i think this seeing this um seeing
these surprising connections is a lot uh
what this what this um
this whole semester is about
okay
so um
okay now
the proof when i get to the proof it's
going to be
so it's really going to be fairly
straightforward
the hard part they're going to be too
hard parts
to understanding this proof
one is after i show it to you you're
going to say wait that's all
and not believe i'm done
i think
okay the other hard part is that
if you're not familiar with complexity
it's going to involve a large number of
complexity classes so i'm just going to
review they're not like the world's most
obscure complexity classes but they're a
fair number of them
okay so i just drew a picture of the
different complexity classes that were
some of which we'll have to talk about
but
like the
um
the full picture is you know we have
polynomial time
then you know above polynomial time are
things like np and con p and you can
look at mp intersect co and p
okay
then you start getting the polynomial
hierarchy p to the np
the second level of the polynomial
harkee that involves two two
alternations of quantifiers there exists
something you know np is there exists
something that you can verify in
polynomial time sigma 2p is there exists
something
so that for all some other things
something you can verify in polynomial
time sigma 3 has three quantifiers and
so on the polynomial hierarchy is any
number of
any fixed number of quantifiers is the
limit then all of that's contained in
exponential time and an exponential time
level the whole pattern repeats itself
okay you have n x intercept cone x and x
f to the n p
um is corresponds to p to the n p
um
and then the exponential hierarchy and
all of that's contained in double
exponential time
so um
so
um
okay
so so that's just like a reminder to us
that all these classes exist
yes
capp is the circuit approximation
probab approximate probability problem
so that's given a circuit
estimate how what fraction of inputs
does the circuit accept up to some
additive error
and
that's like a sort of a complete problem
for bvp actually a little bit more
promise bpp
um because we don't insist that
you know that we do anything
um that we always have um bounded error
it's just that if we could do this we
can
say when there is bounded error
then then we our approximation is
informative if the approximation's like
we really don't know whether the
algorithm usually accepts or usually
rejects
um
okay
so um
so this is
still like a you know we had a kind of
jiu jitsu improving this we're going to
need a different kind of jiu-jitsu in
proving this because we're starting with
an algorithm and we're getting an
impossibility result
so how can we how can we use
an easiness property to get a hardness
property
so
and then the other thing is we have to
do the other thing that's a little
tricky about the statement even in the
statement is we start with a uniform
assumption and we work our way to a
non-uniform assumption
so i'm going to show you actually
there's two very classical
types of argument
that we're going to and we're going to
use versions of this that have been a
little bit updated
um
to to prove this result
and the first one i'm going to say is in
a general argument for shifting
from the non-uniform model to a uniform
model from connections between
non-uniform complexity and uniform
complexity so one of the first places
where those two strands of spaghetti
meet
this is um
actually uh
so back in
like the early 80s maybe 70s
in the paper that introduced the the
notion of of the complexity of you know
introdu reintroduce circuit complexity
into complexity
into what we think of as complexity
so it's a theorem of myers
that he refused to publish
and so was in a paper
by carpent lipton
and the the theorem said says that if if
x is in
p slash poly
then in fact it's in
the second level of the polynomial time
hierarchy
so if we get a if we get a non-uniform
co
containment for x
then in this picture everything between
here and here collapses
so you can actually say x
because it's already known that this is
contained in it it's equivalent to say
it's equal
and
i'm going to give a slightly
different
slightly leading proof hopefully it'll
be helpful to
to ryan's work today later today to
understanding what ryan is doing later
today as well
okay
so um
the
the first step is to just look at
something about exponential time
okay
when we run an and i'm not going to give
the full details of this of this lemma
it's sort of like a
standard thing looking you know you have
to like actually like
talk about machine models
um
but uh
but if you think about it intuitively
you know when we run an algorithm
every algorithm we run is eventually
translated into boolean operations
and the way we translate an algorithm
into boolean operations is very uh
systematic
there isn't like a you know an algorithm
doesn't have huge gaps where of
intuition or imagination that's what
makes it an algorithm so you can pretty
much guess in advance what's going to
happen in step t
in terms of what's happened in previous
steps
so um
so
a
a uniform
circuit
representation
you know a circuit has
its n inputs
and then
m gates and each gate
is some kind of boolean operation
most say two
previously computed gates actually i'm
going to start the labeling of the gates
saying like the first end gates i'm
going to think of as the input so that
this is this makes sense even when we're
doing operations on the input
okay
and um
we'll make it uniform if there's an
algorithm a
that runs in polynomial time
in it says like given
i
it returns
um i1 i2
and
what the two inputs to the gate are and
what the operation is
okay
so um
so the dilemma is that and this is kind
of like tedious but not tedious to to go
through in different machine models but
not so hard to prove is that every
problem in x
as an exponential size
p
uniform
circuit
so there's going to be exponentially
many gates because that's how much time
the algorith you know the the problem
takes to solve but each gate is going to
be easy to tell you in advance
what it does just given the name of the
gate and when i say polynomial remember
if if m is exponential that means the
names of gates are polynomial
in length
and so i itself is going to be a
polynomial length string so when i say
polynomial time i really mean polynomial
time in the input size
and you can scale this down for other
complexities other than x but for x is
fairly nice because it exactly
matches polynomial time
okay so i think this is very believable
if i even know if it would be like tds2
to prove
okay
so now i'm going to approve this meyer
translation just using this lemma
and it actually
is um
is
uh
is
almost immediate
okay
well note that
computing you know computing each gate
is also an exponential time
so in addition to saying what the what
the circuit is going to do on x1 through
xn at the end the last gate this
exponent you know the exponential time
algorithm also computes the value of
every gate
so um
so assume
x was in p slash poly
then
um
then the
you know and we have some some l and l
and x
then um there's this
a circuit
you know uniform circuit
for deciding l
and
computing
the value of the ice gate
is also solvable in x
so what we're going to do so there
because x is in p slash poly there
should be a circuit small circuit that
given x and i tells you the the value of
the ith gate
so we're going to
nondeterministically guess
a polynomial size circuit
c
that given
x
and i
computes
the
value of the either gate on input x
according to these rules
well but then how do we know that that
circuit actually works
okay
um
well
we can't really know that it works but
we could certainly know that it fails
because each eye is supposed to be up i
of g i1 gi2
so um
if it fails it's going to fail at some
gate
so co-non-deterministically
s
and i
you know compute
because the circuit is very uniform we
can compute
the i1 the i2 and the op i
and
verify
that
c of x i
in this case we're looking for a counter
example so we want to verify that it's
different from
up i
of c of x
i1
c of x
i2
so if it if it messes up if the circuit
messes up on x it has to mix up on some
gate
and so we co-non-terminally guess which
gate it messes up on and verify that it
messes up on that key
if it never messes up
then the circuit was correct and so the
value it gives us on x is is actually
the correct answer or an xm is actually
the correct answer
and if you look at it here we have we're
not internally guessing c existentially
guessing c
codon determines so guessing the gate
that it messes up in both of these have
polynomial size descriptions and then
doing a procedure that takes polynomial
time so that's exactly the definition of
the second level of the polynomial time
hierarchy
which is where we want to put it
okay
so um before i go on let me just tell
you
one um
uh
one
modern update for this
that just gives you a slightly better
conclusion
okay but very similar
okay
in the modern update
is to say
okay let's take this very uniform
circuit
and
you know this is a
very you know what we're doing is like
coding when we're doing this spelling
this out we're writing it as a big 3c
and f it's the same as the reduction
from circuit sat to 3c and fsat
okay
and i want to like
be a little bit more lenient about this
for all quantifier
and so what i'm going to do is take this
circuit this uniform circuit
and i'm going to run it through the pcp
construction and in fact actually
doing it in this context in the
exponential time context was actually
done before the pcp theorem was actually
proved so
use the
the proto pcp
of
say bye bye fort now in wound
we can
we can rewrite it as
this verification process
so that
you know we're adding more checks
but making sure that
that if any check fails
a constant fraction of checks
fail
so saying i take this write it as a 3c
and f
run the 3cnf through the pcp theorem or
any previous version of the pcb theorem
that you that you feel like
then
then
what we what we
get is that
instead of like having to look through
all the circuits here do you know
exhaustive search have a
uh
for all quantifier here we can just
randomly sample
gates of the circuit and most of them
are many of them are going to fail
okay so that makes it a a
non-deterministic
guess here but then a random
verification here
and actually puts it in means that we
actually have to add a slightly
add one more class to our diagram merlin
arthur
the class of things that are
have a certificate that's
probabilistically verifiable
okay
and so the update
i'm not really sure who this is who to
attribute this to is that if x is in
piece p slash probably
actually this was in bf and w wasn't it
yeah that this means that
x is actually
not just in sigma 2 but is in a subclass
between np and sigma 2 and seemingly
closer to mp
merlin arthur
so that just makes the the result
just a little bit stronger
but in a way that's really useful
and what what what's really useful about
this is that one of these quantifiers
now involves randomness and we're going
to be using an assumption that allows us
to remove randomness
so this is one ingredient and this is
the ingredient where we're shifting from
a non-uniform assumption to a uniform
conclusion
and
even better a uniform conclusion
involving randomness
okay
so let me give you the other kind of
ingredient it also goes back
way way back
to when
uh
you know when at least to when uh
western complexity theorists were first
studying circuit complexity
as which you know in the eastern bloc it
never stopped
um
um
okay
uh
and it's a kind of logically tricky kind
of argument but it sort of makes sense
and i call it the the shelf collapsing
argument
so it isn't quite true that we have no
lower bounds for circuits what we have
are lower bounds for circuits that are
way way up here
in this hierarchy and we'd like to move
them lower in the hierarchy so the shelf
class method is a way of moving
results that you know hardness results
that you know for things way up in the
hierarchy
lower in the hierarchy
and there's like unconditional shell
collapsing results and
in conditional shelf collapsing results
i'm going to see some of both
so the way i view it
is
we have this kind of in the in a room
that we can't quite see into there's a
bookcase
okay
and
on the top shelf of the bookcase we see
that there's a very heavy object
okay
and we can't quite see the lower half of
the bookcase
but um
but um
we're going to argue that there's a
heavy object lower in the bookcase
so and the way we're going to argue it
is to say either one of two cases
okay
either there's a pretty heavy object
lower in the bookcase
and we're done or
there's nothing in the in the lower
shelf of the bookcase
that bookcase shelf is not very strong
we have a heavy object up here
so
the bookcase the shelf is gonna give
and then the heavy objects will fall
into the lower shelf
so
either there's something already there
or there soon will be something there
okay
and so that's that's the whole argument
okay so um so i think like the first
prototypical uh shelf collapsing
argument was due to ravi kanan who's
around here somewhere
um
in general i mean
um
saw him yesterday
uh
and it says uh it shows that um
it's an unconditional self-collapsing
argument it shows that sigma 2x
is not contained in p slash poly
there are a couple of other things in
his in his paper
okay maybe he cared about more
this is again it's like from the early
80s i think i don't remember exactly
okay and here was his argument
the first thing he did was say well we
know um
this is even more classical result
riordan and and shannon showed
there exists a function f on n bits so
that the size of f
is this exponential 2 to the n over n
i'll make i
i guess there's like some fixed constant
sorry yeah okay sorry
so i'll say it again
there's this classical result of riordan
and shannon
does say there exists a function f is
this better
yeah
so that the psi the minimal size of f
is on the order of 2 to the n over n and
you know they they pinned it down very
precisely for us all that's important is
that there are functions there exists
functions by accounting argument that
take exponential circuit complexity
okay
so um
so kanan's first argument
involves saying
what is the value
of the first
in the lexicographical sense
uh
maximal hardness
function
on x
so you look for all functions on two to
the on n bits you can express them as
truth tables of size two to the n
you look to see for each one
you buy exhaustive search look through
all circuits that might be computing
them see whether the circuit actually
computes them isolate their complexity
take the one and maximal complexity
which is two to the n over n and
evaluate take the you know there are
many of them that have that complexity
take the first one in lexicographical
order and
evaluate it on x
and if you like go through all of this
this actually involves a number of
quantifiers each of which is
exponentially long
but it's a fixed number of quantifiers
um and so you can show that this
and it's this certainly you know what
we're having a name is this this is
actually like the
you know the function this is computing
by another name is this first
electrographically
first hard function which by definition
is hard
the first hard function is hard
so um
so
so this
is a hard function and if you look
through the logical structure it's
really just in like
sigma 3
i should say sigma sub 3
in the exponential time hierarchy
so this hard function is up near the top
of our diagram
but he promised us a hard function
slightly lower
okay so how does he do this
well by the shelf collapse argument
so the
the top shelf
is sigma 3
x
and we know there's a really hard
function up in sigma 3x
okay
okay
so um
the shelf that we can't see
is going to be x
okay
and somehow he's reasoning about sigma
2x
okay but what we're going to show is
that there if there isn't a weight here
to keep the whole shelf up we get a the
the shelf breaks at this level
so you know the number one above it the
one below at the downstairs neighbor is
sigma 2x
so um so why is this true
well he says uh
either
x was in piecewise poly
or not
that's pretty clear
not saying a lot
but
what
meyer already showed is that if x was in
d slash poly
then
x equals
sigma 2p and if you translate that up so
you know we get this collapse all the
way down here if you
that
by a padding argument gives you the same
collapse the analogous collapse up here
so that means all of this collapses down
to sigma 2x
and sigma 3x was in the middle there
so
um it follows that sigma 3x
equals sigma 2x
and we know the sigma so the that means
the ceiling collapses on on sigma 2x and
the heavy thing falls into the into the
sigma 2's apartment
okay
so um
so if
if it is in p slash poly the shelf
collapses
well it might not be in p slash poly
though it's actually probably not in p
slash poly
but what do we know if it's not a p
slash poly
then we've got something hard way down
here and that's contained in this
okay
then
uh
then
certainly sigma
2x
so either way
uh canon wins
and
you know so i like win-win arguments
that give you lower bounds
and a lot more of them
not trying to avoid them
okay
so let's say like it's really easy but
logically strange
because here we're saying we either win
or we win
but we don't know whether which one
which way we win
so we're going to follow the
the same kind of model
in the randomness setting
okay so what did we want to show
uh so we wanted to show
that um
so what was
the claim that
um
okay
i'm really almost done
we're claiming
that okay i'm almost done in mms almost
out of time
those two are coincidental
that if
c-a-p-p
is contained in
p is is in p
then we get
nx intercept coin x
is not contained in piece large pond
and we're going to use the same kind of
win-win
shelf collapsing argument
and with the same kind of down
base of the the of the of the apartment
building
okay so um
so first we'll assume
that capp
is in
p
and one you know that means that we can
solve any kind of de-randomization
problem
and in particular that part about
verifying certificates for things is in
and is it can be done in polynomial time
so it follows from this
that m a is actually equal to np
okay
um
so if in addition
if x was in p slash poly
and again this is one case it's either
there or it's not
okay if x was in p slash probably we
said
then x
equals m a and actually i'm now going to
say
one other condition x is closed under
complement so it's also equal to co-ma
and so it's equal to m a intersect
column a
and then we already said that m a is
just now another because cap is easy m a
is just another name for np
so this is np intersect column b
so now we get a collapse all the way
with this assumption we get the collapse
if x was easy all the way down to np
intercept
intersection
okay
well that means
you know everything in the middle like
sigma 3p collapses down to np intercept
co and p and when we translate up
you know we get like x x
equals sigma three x
equals
uh nx
intersect coin x
um
and so in particular and x intersect
coin x so that means this hard problem
dropped all the way down to just above x
to n x bin or second x
so and this is has has very hard
problems
okay so that's if x you know under the
unlikely event that x expects contained
in p-slash poly then we get a circuit
lower bound we moved our known circuit
lower bound all the way down to an
x-intercept colon x
but what if x is not in p-slash poly
it answers itself
and in particular and x-intercept colon
x is not in p slash probably so we get
the same consequence either way
okay now we could do a lot more work and
we did to try to get quantitative
versions
that
that are that are tighter so you know
assuming cap has a sub-exponential
algorithm what do you what kind of
consequence do you get assuming uh can
we get um you know assuming it's in
polynomial time can we get a better
circuit lower bound than just super
polynomial
so
there's more work to be done but this is
the basic idea
and the bell roll tolls
first transformation
what could you talk about tomorrow
so tomorrow i'm actually going to talk
about
so this is not how we proved it
originally we proved it originally using
something called the easy witness lemma
which is something like a search versus
decision
lemma for non-uniform complexity for nx
and uh it so we no longer sort of like
use these we all no longer need the easy
witness lemma for many of the
randomization connections but actually
it comes up again uh in ryan's work
relating sad algorithms to
to
lower bounds so i'm going to talk about
sort of
a lemma that we thought was really
interesting got orphan temporo
temporarily and then got adopted by ryan
just just briefly going back to um
the significance of sigma 2x as the you
know in this proof is that on the one
hand it's between x and sigma 3 and x
yeah on the other hand it's like um at
least class that we know how to sort of
diagonalize against sigma 2p is that
well so the smallest class we know how
diagonal size is really like sigma 3.
and we're moving it down and canon moved
it down to sigma 2 by this logical
twist of
right but in the case where i mean
so
and i should say you know that um
that
by you know by using this modern version
using the pcp theorem you can actually
move it down a little further to things
like max and that was done by fort now
and santana or
am i getting the co-author wrong
and it's been i think it's even been
moved down just a slight amount
something like to bpp to the
b p x to the n p or something like this
but there was just one part of the
argument you didn't write down just
suppose that
x is in p slash poly yeah x equals sigma
two p
right and
then uh that is not equal to sigma 2x
because of a time hierarchy theorem
oh so you try to do it that way um
so and that's
yes that would that's
in fact how we using time hierarchy
theorems not for sigma 2 but for
um
for not so like sigma the thing is then
you have to sigma 2 is a non-terministic
class it's like np to the np so you have
to use the variance of non-deterministic
time hierarchy theorems that are
actually
significantly more complex than the
deterministic time hierarchy theorems
so um
so you can do it that way
but probably not in 10 minutes
i was just trying to understand the
argument that you were sketching yeah no
the argument i'm sketching is much
simple it's just straightforward only
use the time hierarchy theorem at all we
just know there's a hard problem in
sigma 3x
and we know that if there is no hard
problem in sigma 2x in sigma in x
then sigma 2 3 x and sigma 2x are just
different names for the same class
because the the polynomial time
hierarchy collapses and because the
polynomial time hierarchy collapses and
and rescaling
gives you the exponential time hierarchy
collapsing so i squared over that one
detail but it's actually
pretty standard and pretty easy
yes
later on you made it specialized the
assumption was
let's say
you say
follow me
that's friday yeah
i was going to ask if you're going to
say something about that friday i will
hopefully
thank you